hi there Steve here again language
learning which is the subject that I
talked about the most language learning
and the salami the there was in a number
of sort of issues people talk about the
salami approach which means that you'd
sort of one slice at a time you deal
with the problem if you have a very
messy room to clean up it can look
overwhelming but if you slowly one item
at a time start to clean up the room
pretty soon the room is clean it's not
gonna get any dirtier it can only get
cleaner and if you have what seems to be
a like an assignment for school and it
looks like a tremendously onerous
assignment but if you sit down and one
slice at a time start dealing with what
has to be done all of a sudden instead
of having this great burden hanging over
your head you're starting to see your
way through to completing the task so I
think this is often a very important
sort of attitude to have when you when
you feel you have a great you know
challenging task or what looks to be a
lot of work you just start doing it and
you learn and you do more and the task
no longer grows it's like it's like that
Chairman Mao's famous story the foolish
old man who moved the mountain and he
and he the son were gonna dig this
mountain which was I don't know blocking
his in the way of his rice field or
something and people told him don't be
so foolish you can't you know dig the
mountain away and he said well I'm gonna
dig my son's gonna dig and his son after
him and the mountain is not gonna get
any bigger well that's a bit extreme but
it's the same idea one slice at a time
one bit at a time we can overcome
actually quite significant challenges so
language learning is very much like that
sometimes you don't feel like doing
anything go and even do just a little
like after this I haven't done much
today I've been working in the garden
cleaning my deck I'm gonna sit down and
read a few Ukrainian stories on my iPad
that I downloaded today and because I
know that just every little bit counts
one little bit at a time I got to stay
with it stay with it stay with it one
slice at a time things start to become
clearer things start to stick as long as
you persist and just keep on slicing
away at the salami so that's my little
short message today keep on slicing away
at your language salami
bye for now